The home screen of a website or
the loading screen of your mobile app,
will be the first impression for users.
And you want to make sure
that you get this right.
Here's Udacity's homepage
as of April 2015.
A clear goal headlines the page, and
there's plenty of white space around
the headlines, and
the tagline to draw users into them.
Homepages like this one should
answer these questions.
What is this?
What is being offered?
What can I do here?
And how do I start?
In Udacity's case, the how can I get
started comes just below the fold
with a description of
the Nanodegree program.
You want all of this
information to be present, but
you should also be careful
not to overwhelm your users.
You want users to have a clear
understanding of what you offer, and
then you can link to other pages for
users to learn more about
your product or services.
Many companies put those
links in the footer.
Going back up to the top of
the homepage, we can see that from here,
I could sign up for an account, or
I could sign in if I'm an existing user.
To learn more about how
nanodegrees work in particular
I could click on one of these.
Homepages are tricky in
that they need to do a lot.
But you want to be careful about
adding more and more to that page so
sometimes you might have a landing page,
like this one.
Landing pages are for specific products
that you want to show to your users.
They allow you to focus on
one particular product.
Notice that here,
there's a clear call to action.
I can get a sense about what this
product is from the copy on the page and
also from this background image.
Scrolling down, I can even get
more details about the program.
To learn more about
designing homepages and
landing pages, check out the articles
that are linked in the Instructor Notes.
At the very least, you need to
strive for an informative page, and
at the best,
your homepage should be memorable.
It's important to keep in mind that
your homepage doesn't have to be static.
It should be a work in progress.
Here's another version
of the Udacity homepage.
And notice that it's changed slightly.
We have different copy and these
images have been condensed together.
Your homepage might also be dynamic in
that you might be AB testing certain
features of it to see what
drives users actions.
You might also just be trying to refine
your value proposition for your users.
And even before that homepage,
this is what Udacity's homepage
looked like once upon a time.
As you can see,
it's not as informative or
clear at answering the questions,
what is this and what can I do here?
At the end of the day, you want to
make a fantastic first impression.
It's really up to you
to delight users so
that way they come to know who you
are and what you have to offer.
Now it's your turn to do a little
investigation of your own.
I'd like you to find three homepages for
relatively new companies and
analyze them.
You want to get a feel for
what type of information and
elements live on their homepages.
For each of the homepages you
should ask yourself: what
elements comprise the homepage, what are
the main calls to action, what does that
homepage say about the company,
its users and the value proposition?
And what are the most likely flows
from the homepage to
other places on the site?
In other words,
what could you do from the homepage?
Finally, what are some
of the similarities and
differences you see across
the homepages you looked at?
Write a post that answers
these questions and
share it on the discussions.
Once you're ready,
check this box to continue